en ce moment plus que jamais la télé
réalité se réinventer tente de changer
pour conquérir un nouveau public
après maman est célèbre voilà que tu es
fx a décidé de se lancer dans un nouveau
format sur la vraie vie des femmes de
footballeurs les wags c'est le journal
le parisien qui révèle cette information
et donne plus de précisions sur le
potentiel casting de cette émission
on y retrouverait par exemple la femme
de wesley lautoa anne-sophie godet la
femme du joueur de dijon n'est pas une
inconnue puisque sur les réseaux sociaux
elle cumule déjà plus de 500 mille
abonnés le pseudo l'armoire de sauce au
casting également la compagne d'un
ancien cadre du tfc
l'ex candidate de télé-réalité mélanie
la femme du joueur de manchester united
anthony martial aurait quant à elle
refusé de participer alors bientôt une
téléréalité sur les femmes de
footballeurs j'y crois ce sera donc jour
sur tf6 berça ces nouveaux principes
c'est danse avec les stars ou ya pas de
star à louis des autres on a dit seront
alors une magali à toutes les coulisses
et tous les impôts d'abord ça vaut
combien tout ça ben oui moi c'est est ce
que ça change
je trouve que c'est super c'est un super
concept parce que les wags ça fait rêver
on va appeler sir passionne et ses
intrigues les gens donc pourquoi pas je
trouve ça novateur après l'idée mouallem
avait été soufflée il ya très longtemps
par un ministre qui sait qu'il faut que
ça s'était bien au contraire elle m'a
proposé aussi à l'époque à maurice et
oui c'est vrai parlé il ya quelques
années et je pense que peut-être
certains lui ont piqué son idée mais là
je ne sais pas je veux pas parler des
choses
mais attention ne créons pas de partir
et fait une femme de
[Musique]
le jeu de combat c'est le dernier
oui ou est ce que tu vois que ça change
excusez moi mais c'est tout des
bombasses refaite très bien elle a rien
de hrw et je peux dire est une fille n'a
pas grand chose de ses voitures alors
c'est une bonne occasion loupée
d'origine
qu'il fasse une mais tellement vous
allez là qui fait mal en pis et une
banda ça sera un peu pareil mais perd le
maillot n'est pas le nom mais moi je
vais tester ça c'était de le faire à
part maintenant en 2005 je crois il ya
eu une émission anglaise sur les wags
c'est ça ouais voilà qui est arrivé en
france n'a pas du tout marché ça avait
basculé de m6 à une petite sieste
d'heure bon moi j'y crois pas beaucoup
oui oui oui en fait ce que je voulais
préciser c'est que normalement il y aura
aussi une femme d'un joueur de l'équipe
de france de football
l'ancien bleu non non non martial on
sait vraiment pas sûr à prix modique à
un peu plus qu'à lui même celui qu'on a
pas la joie
et pour revenir sur emilie nef naf je
suis assez d'accord avec moi younes que
c'est quand même elle qui est à
l'origine de maman et celle qui a un
gros carton sur tf6
et c'est elle qui avait eu l'idée donc
là m'a fait vraiment elle a quelque
chose dans le loft of serait d'abord été
des gens sérieux je m'emballe m